nor again woman is suing two of our
doctors and a nurse practitioner for
invasive surgery she says were
unnecessary
Alicia cooked more claims they told her
that she tested positive for
cancer-causing genes so she then had her
breasts and her uterus removed and after
these preventative surgeries she learned
those genetic tests were negative cook
more tells Carter Evans she hopes her
experience can help others now to ask
the right questions
they wrote Alicia cook Moore's life
changed dramatically after having a
double mastectomy and hysterectomy last
year as a precaution the 36 year old had
been told a genetic test she took
indicated a high risk for cancer when
you found out that you didn't have those
genetic markers and you didn't need
those surgeries how did you react in a
lawsuit filed last week cook Moore
claims the doctor who performed her
hysterectomy and her nurse practitioner
told her she had Lynch syndrome cancer
genes associated with increased risk of
endometrial ovarian and other cancers I
think I went numb that's kind of
shocking to hear she alleges dr. William
Fitz recommended and performed a
preventive hysterectomy at this Southern
Oregon Hospital two months later another
surgeon dr. Jessica Carlson gave her a
preventive double mastectomy she says it
was only after painful complications
prompted her to see another doctor that
she discovered her genetic tests were
misread she did not have the
cancer-causing genes nobody checked into
this nobody who checked with my lab I
hold my lab they said we never said that
results are negative now she's suing the
three medical professionals and their
medical offices for 1.8 million dollars
this state maximum her attorney
Christopher Coble says it's a blatant
case of malpractice there's not a lot of
things that surprise me anymore but that
was certainly something that surprised
me we reached out to the defendants in
the case
the medical practice CEO and dr. Fitts
attorneys say they cannot comment on
pending litigation second opinions are
critical dr. David agus is an oncologist
and CBS News medical contributor you
have to take charge of your own data and
actually look at the numbers and talk
Alicia cook bore now hopes others learn
from her medical mistake you didn't feel
there was a need for a second opinion
you know no I trusted them and that's
maybe where I went wrong for CBS this
morning Carter Evans
Brookings Horrigan really tough story a
reminder get a second opinion